depuis nous sommes à la marolle en
sologne pour la fête de berlines
bergogne on retrouve en direct sur place
flavien texier bonsoir flavian je vois
que vous avez changé de tenue bonsoir et
des cas vous êtes très observatrice
effectivement j'ai changé de tenue parce
qu'on a décidé ce soir de se fondre dans
la foule
ça s'appelle une bio décès en fait la
tenue que l'on portait autrefois après
une dure journée de travail aux champs
voilà vous savez tout bienvenue à vous
qui nous rejoignent et ici on a plein de
choses à vous raconter on a des pas
d'image à vous montrer et nous sommes
toujours en compagnie d'un soleil qui
est dans une semaine par ben qui est
avec nous depuis la mi-journée pour
soirs comme ça alors je vois que vous
aussi vous avez une tenue traditionnelle
oui j'ai l'habitude additionnel de la
paysanne solognote donc avec une vue un
tablier et une blouse alors ça paraît
évident vous n'avez pas qu une fugue
cette époque mais par contre la fête
vous savez précisément de quoi il s'agit
c'est quoi qu'est ce qu'on a fait ici
toute la journée alors berline werden
c'est une grande fête du patrimoine
rural qui est organisée par le cp ce qui
change de commune tous les ans et donc
c'est une fête qui est organisée avec la
commune ou qui accueille la fête et du
coup il y à un grand défilé d'attelages
qui est le moment phare de la fête avec
aussi un marché à l'ancienne et d'autres
plein d'autres animations thème avec les
années 20 et les années trop pour avoir
tout ça dans quelques instants il cps ça
veut dire quoi
union pour la culture populaire au seul
à nier on va voir tout de suite quelques
images que nous avons tourné au cours de
la journée parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre ici que le village s'est
métamorphosée oui la déco on a
complètement changé la déco on a mis des
vieilles enseignes
on a mis on a installé un vieux marché
avec de la paille avec les produits que
les habitants ont récolté eux-mêmes dans
leur jardin
on a mis des charrettes on a mis plein
de matériel agricole
tous les bénévoles tous les habitants
ont mis la main à la pâte vous parlez
des attelages tout à l'heure on va
regarder tout de suite quelques images
c'est un reportage que nous avons tourné
en milieu d'après-midi les images
justement c'est toujours etienne braye
leçon c'est toujours philippe roy et au
montage sa chance ce soir quand ça
change ça change et ses frais de marche
qui s'y colle regardez
avis à la population à 4h45 hambourg du
maire ici même sur la place publique
qu'on se le dise le ton est donné
quelques discours de bienvenue et la
fête peut commencer
ici et là des animations sont proposées
aux visiteurs un retour dans le passé
très apprécié ah bah moi je suis un fana
ça fait 20 ans je suis en train d'en
soleil et je viens ma patrie au coin
d'une rue une bénévole pousse la
chansonnette
très vite le refrain est sur toutes les
lèvres car à la marolle en sologne
on connaît la chanson après
la la la la la la la
ah lalala lalala lalala c'est une pop
ouvrière
vous la chantier tout petit j'avais
trois quatre heures ça date de loin
tiens voilà monsieur le curé encore un
bénévoles déguisés qui se prend au jeu
moi ce qui vous plaît dans ces
rassemblements c'est que ça me donne
l'occasion de retrouver tous mes
paroissiens et paroissiennes qui ne
viennent malheureusement pas souvent à
confesse
et j'ai eu l'occasion véritablement de
pouvoir entendre en confession de
nombreuses personnes sur des attelages
on remonte le temps nous en profitons
pour connaître la signification de
berling berdoyes le fameux nom donné à
cette fête alors l'expression de merde
hivernaux bien du bruit de fond est
décalé et grande voiture quand elle
roule
elles font alors ça c'est pas nous qui
sommes à l'initiative c'est du cps qui a
trouvé ce nom un rdv redonnions voilà
à la marolle en sologne la journée se
termine en musique quelques pas de danse
et le tour est joué
[Musique]
retour ici en direct depuis la marolle
en sologne une autre image qu'on va vous
montrer tout de suite c'est une récolte
de pommes de terre etc
anne solenne qui va nous raconter tout
ça alors on a planté 1600 pieds de
pommes de terre le 31 mai dernier tour
pour voir les récolter aujourd'hui avec
une vieille arrache nous avons nous été
retiré par des boeufs et on a récolté
environ 700 kg de pommes de terre qu'on
a redistribué au public
ça c'est un vrai temps fort toute
dernière question c'est quoi l'objectif
de cette fête pour plus tard l'objectif
c'est de mettre en valeur le patrimoine
traditionnel local et de le faire
partager aux générations qui n'ont pas
connu les années 20 les années 30
merci infiniment anne solenne de nous
avoir accompagnés tout au long de la
journée rebecca c'est clair on a passé
trois belles journées avec vous en
sologne
je vous laisse parce que figurez-vous
jeunes l'apprendre je suis corvée de
pommes de terre ce soir à bientôt
aya un bon courage flavien a bientôt
c'était la dernière page et on vous
retrouvera bien sûr pour d'autres sujets